you recently said and i love this that
you're at a phase in your career where
you're trying to impress your kids yes
is there any other work that you've
shown them of yours that they've been
impressed by
um i am like very very into this
obviously for them because they were
just
so happy
to come visit set and they were so
excited to see me wearing a cape and of
course so excited that there's like an
action figure now so that was really
really um fun to get to be in something
that they were so excited about um my
son's a huge comedy fan so he's been
really
he he was really happy to discover like
that i'd done an episode of the simpsons
i really like you bart that is such a
girl thing to say um
and that i had been on um saturday night
live why don't you fill us in on what
it's like to be you okay you [ __ ] i'm
sorry what yeah
your husband and his best friend
[Music]
like he that made him that that gave him
me a lot of like cool points for him
cool mom points what wowed them the most
on set i could only imagine what it's
like being a part of a marble sat like
that
i think all of it i can't i i can't
pinpoint like i mean
i think tyka really impressed them a lot
because he's just so
creative and so funny and he was able to
come up with so much on the spot that
uh i think that really
like
they were really blown away by him my uh
sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right it's our mighty thor
you are absolutely
brilliant in this film what was it like
for you
watching on the big screen
it was um really surreal to to watch i
mean also these these movies have so
much um
incredible visual effects that
we obviously aren't privy to while we're
shooting a lot of it we're shooting with
blue screens green screens so um it's
just like absolutely
incredible to get to see the finished
product and you're in all these places
that you've never actually been to in
real life
now having the cast back together the
gang reuniting your history with chris
christian and tessa how much did having
that make this reunion so much sweeter
it was incredible to have that um
rapport already before and and comfort
with chris and with tessa tyke is
so warm and fun that it was like you
know even though he was new to me
and i was new to him it felt really like
um
like comfortable immediately how is it
true that taika would kind of just throw
the script out the window sometimes and
you guys would just improv
i mean it was really
so radical of him on this kind of budget
and this kind of pressure
to be that free and that spontaneous and
just
really he loves everything to be
like fresh and
and spontaneous so so
pretty much everything is improvised do
you like operating in that mode
it was really fun i mean it's really
it's a completely different experience
as an actor because your biggest work is
to
come and be open instead of like having
kind of preparation and a plan and like
know what you're doing and feeling like
you have control over
your performance um and so it was
definitely a new
thing to experience but i loved it like
i i i wish i could go back and
do do it again because after having had
the experience because it's um it's
like you get so much after you
understand kind of the mechanics of it
that you feel like you want to use that
knowledge but hands down you have the
best group to be able to do that with i
mean
it's it's incredible i mean sometimes i
would just get
like lost watching tycho and chris and
tessa spitfalling with each other i was
like oh oh oh yeah this is this is
amazing there were a few moments where
we all got lost watching chris hemsworth
channel
now no spoilers here but if given the
opportunity to be a part of the mcu in
the future how in are you i am open for
anything so um yeah it's it's exciting
that the world is so large now within
the mcu that um you know it does feel
like everything is possible speaking of
large natalie your arms in this film he
reclaimed his title
as the one and only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
what was the training process like for
you well it was really exciting to be
cast as a character who's like six foot
when i'm 5'3 i think that's a pretty
unusual thing to happen and so um it was
wonderful to
you know imagine myself as big as
possible obviously there's a lot of
movie magic involved there i can't i
can't just grow um but it was it was an
incredible challenge to try and like
take up as much space as possible i
think as women were often asked to make
ourselves as small as possible so it was
it was an incredible incredible
challenge what did that movie magic look
like how did they make you go from five
foot three to six feet tall well i mean
there's a lot of um there's a lot that
goes on um
one thing was that they would build me
like a deck
every time i was walking or moving in a
scene that would take me for my path and
poor chris and tessa would have to like
navigate getting over it if they need to
needed to walk but i was basically had a
platform a lot of the time that was one
aspect
of course there's also like a lot of
computer effects that help as well now
going back to the workout routine chris
told me that there were a lot of ice
baths involved and the ladies actually
were the champs when it came to the ice
baths
so we had a big ice bath there which
we'd rotate through and and that was
that became the kind of
the most noise was made in that thing
how did a real test of strength how did
she take the ice bath because that i
feel like is easy for you kick in my ass
now i i've done it a bit but i'd sort of
was keeping my time in there to sort of
a minute too and she came in first day
and did three three and a half minutes
and so then we all have to try and do
three minutes and
not me really
tessa's amazing
um with it but i'm i'm not very good at
pain like i'm good at
like
they're i have to find the things that i
really like enjoy and i'll do that like
the saunas because saunas are a big part
of it too i'm like great i'll do songs
and steam rooms
i like the exercising and the work
training every morning like i can do
that ice bath is not for me but tess is
amazing at it tess is like
tepha's
tessa is tough like it's like that is a
really hard hard thing to do tough tessa
thompson yes we are two years away from
celebrating 30 years since your first
acting credit what exactly do you do for
a living cleaner you mean your hit man
cool what would you say is the secret to
your longevity in this business
oh god
like um
i don't know i guess it's been
like having
um
having a life that's apart from my um
acting work because i think
i always have been able to go back and
really enjoy my life
which has probably prevented me from
like doing too much and getting like
burnt out you know i think it like can
really be a lot to like constantly be
working and um i haven't i haven't been
like back to back i've always you know
there have been times i've taken two
years off one year off um
so uh yeah i think i think rest rest is
always important
[Music]